he's one of our favorites we've been
waiting for him to appear on this show
and that moment has arrived
from the seattle seahawks dk metcalf how
are you dk
i'm good how are you i'm better for
talking to you
how's life for you dk metcalf happy
birthday by the way happy birthday
belated
yesterday thank you thank you um
life is life is great um you know we
back winning so
so that's always good and um you know
i'm on a pretty good tenure so we gotta
we got a chance to do something special
uh go deep in the playoffs and uh you
know that's the exciting part
what makes you tech dk what makes you
tick
i don't know you got to catch me in a
moment it's hard to think of
something right off the top of my head
right now okay so this moment is not
that moment
is what you're saying no no no
no all right so because i just love
you know the first time i you know got
to
see you in person was when i was
broadcasting the combine
okay and then you go through your your
combine
and the nfl network cameras catch you
facetiming
somebody and you were in tears who were
you talking to at that
point in time dk where are those people
i was talking to my mom
what was going through your mind my mom
back home
what was going through your mind at that
point um for you
it was just no sigh of relief um
she know how how much i worked and how
hard i worked and
you know i didn't get to see her for
four months um
because i was i was training for the
combine but uh you know just to
hear her say how proud of me she was
um you know that just really made me
tear up and
um you know i was just ready to ready to
see my family ready to get back home
so if i was out of the booth and had and
was equipped with
the numbers statistics pictures video
from 2020 and i told you this is what
you're gonna do
what would that kid have said on that
day dk metcalf
um if it's in god's will then let it be
done i'm not
i'm not gonna say i i plan for this
season to go you know how it was but um
you know what better timing and um you
know what better
what better chance to give god all the
glory um you know from
you know sitting in the hospital bed
breaking my neck to
you know being one of the top receivers
in the league right now
um you know i'm just i'm just blessed to
have this opportunity
but to be you know part of a team that
that's doing great on sundays and
um you know let's just keep uh working
and just keep rolling how has russell
helped you
with your development personally
professionally
dk metcalf how has he helped um
he's mainly helped me um you know on and
off the field uh in my mind him tyler
uh demo dwayne brown bobby um i kind of
kind of stick to them and uh you know
take take heat to
you know everything that they say and
try to mimic uh you know all of their
off the field um
you know steps uh with recovery and you
know talking about football and life and
you know goals that that we have um but
my best conversations are on thursdays
uh before practice talking to bobby um
you know mainly about about life
football on goals
um you know the all-pro seasons that
he's had
the teams that that won the super bowl
and that went back-to-back
um so it was just like like the
conversations with bobby
um before practice are always the best
so bobby as in bobby wagner who is
another person i
i adore i just love his game and i love
what he's all about that's a that's a
self-made man right there
in bobby wagner can you just let me in a
little bit on that conversation
let all the 12s who are probably dying
to be a fly on the wall of that
conversation what what what exactly are
you going back and forth how are you
chopping it up with bobby wagner
d.k metcalf um
it was one uh thursday we were looking
out on
the field and um he saw numbers like uh
29
you know earl thomas with that number um
31 uh cam chancellor with a number and
they're not retired yet
and they're great players and bobby told
me he was like when i take this jersey
off nobody else is going to wear it so
that's another goal that i had to you
know put on my wall put on
my uh my goal board is is you know when
i leave the seattle seahawks number 14
is going to be retired
and um you know i go go to practice go
to meetings
uh go ahead and go into every game
knowing that all right i gotta retire
this jersey
by the time i leave so um just the goals
that we have in life and
and um you know on the football field so
is there an actual goals board of dk
metcalf somewhere like an actual
tangible board or is this just something
for mentally you're doing is there an
actual board
dk oh no i got it i got a gold board in
my house
what does it look like is it like a
grease board or uh what is it
what is the goals board it's a regular
white board that i do
okay i wrote a couple of 20 20 goes on
life goals football goes team goals
um something that i can i can hold
myself accountable for
how much is on there do you want to and
what can you share that's on that board
um
oh i can share like um i haven't had a
thousand yards since high school so
this year is the first time that i've
had a thousand yards um
let's check that out for ten touchdowns
um i wrote
i wrote that on uh the board and i got
it okay um
i i said that we got to make it to the
nfc championship this year
uh last year we're a game short okay um
so that's on there
i'm ready to check that one off um
win the super bowl playing 10 years in
the league
at least um you know taking down some
more
uh receiver records uh that's that's
holding uh standing in
uh in the nfl okay um where is on that
on that goals board run down a grown
grown-ass man like buddha baker on
national television is that on that
board
dk there's not necessarily a goal it's
just something i looked i looked like i
i had to do
um i mean that's not a goal i just had
to do it in that moment um
you know i'm trying to win win a super
bowl and
and those kinds of plays are is what um
you know leads to
that happening so um i mean that's
just like uh russ extending the play and
then throwing a a toe drag
uh touchdown uh tyler locking in the
back of the end zone so
i mean those players about equivalent to
me so walk me through the moment where
you saw buddha
pick off ross and go in the other
direction walk me through that one dk
i've been dying to ask you about this
for about two months i mean when i when
i saw it
uh he let the ball go i saw buddha just
floating in the air
uh letting the ball uh hit him in his
chest and then
when his feet hit the ground and he
started running i just the only thing in
my mind was go get him
and not just i just ran that's it just
simple you just ran
and then you ran him down uh and i'm
just saying okay
that's it's that simple okay i got to
think about that for the 40-yard dash
this year
it's just keep it simple basically what
you're telling me
right dk do you have any advice on that
for me okay
you can't never do too much when you run
it okay well that's my problem i try to
do too much
but that's just who i am that's how i'm
wired uh yeah
and then you know even with a six seven
yard head start you run straight through
me but that's okay
i it's not like i see it 50 million
times a day every day on twitter
and i mean your your moment of running
down buddha is
is a meme um what do you think of every
single time you see that you must see it
it's about it's
it's about 50 million a day and robert
griffin used the latest one about
putting brown's lead over buddha and
over you the words lamar after pooping
did you see that one
dk yes i thought um
i'm kind of tired of them right now oh
okay all right
all right i mean it's just like the
shirtless pick i'm i'm
proud of seeing that one as well but
um you know this this this the life i
have and i got it
you know just think just look at the
positive um yeah about it and
you know thank god nobody else uh he put
me in this position because he knew i
can handle it so
well um yeah so i just thank him for the
meeting
all right well in that regard dk i know
we we're we're just getting to meet here
and uh if you don't mind me just
uh giving you a a couple of pieces of
advice on
on this front if you don't mind um if
you look the way you look
you should never have a problem with a
shirtless photograph being shown
around like my god i would take
literally two seconds of life
to have that for me literally would take
that
so on behalf of all other human beings
and
and men certainly of my age and my dad
bod
god bless you just let it go i would i
would like every two seconds
so i hope you don't mind me saying don't
worry about that stuff
okay dk sorry yes sir thank you
okay seriously do that now i do have
just a couple other questions for you
certainly from my kids
uh dk because you are uh an inspiration
to so many and kids
i don't know if you're aware of this
kids just love they just love watching
you play i mean there's something about
your
way you go about it maybe it is your
size your body your spirit i don't know
what it is
and also my kids want to know what
what's with the pacifier
um in your mouth as your mouth guard
where did that one come from
dk um
so i know the owner of battle
mouthpieces i've been knowing them since
i was in high school
and i was just shopping on his website
one day from out pieces to where and i
saw
uh the binky and i just decided to uh
you know put it on the first game of the
season not not thinking anything about
it and
you know kind of kind of took off after
the first game
um you know i play aggressive i play
mean on the field but you know i got a
binky in my mouth
uh you know i'm young in the league but
i play like a grown man is what i like
to say
um about the bank well your huggies have
certainly dropped that's for sure
in 2020 and then how do you decide your
hair color
how do you decide that dk what's the
process there
this is very spontaneous so whatever i'm
thinking
at that moment of the day i like i do it
um probably every friday every thursday
uh every every other week um i know last
week it was about to be lime green
and then out of the blue i just said
yeah let's do half
half blue half purple so i mean
it just depends on how i feel that day
so we don't know like literally for
washington football team
which is one of the top defenses and
certainly secondaries
and is a major challenge for you coming
up this weekend you do not know
right now as we're talking on a on a
thursday morning what your hair color is
going to be this weekend
correct so what you're saying correct
okay
great it's probably going to be the same
i'm going to keep it the same this week
all right next week it's going to be
up in the air okay and then last one for
you um
what message should we give to any other
defensive coordinators who have
coordinated against calvin johnson
what uh what should we tell them
when they are playing against the
seattle seahawks what message should we
tell them
dk
stop comparing me to people
i'm me and playing against me don't
don't play against anybody else
beware of dogs i'm thinking uh you asked
what
you asked me what made me tick yes sir
and that's one thing that does make me
feel
what is compared to people why i mean if
what what if they're
all-time greats like calvin you just
that's still not that's still not good
enough
um calvin is calvin i'm i'm me
he's it's a blessing uh to be compared
to him
um you know i i take the compliment
um with a grain of salt and i just keep
pushing but um
you know it's i'm me and i'm trying to
pay it my own way
and be my own grade i'm not trying to be
like anybody else well dk
it has been a pleasure to watch your
ascendancy
and i cannot wait to see just how high
this ceiling is i hope this is the first
of many times that we get to chat here
on the show
it has been an absolute delight watching
you play and um
and then again you know uh i'm i'm gonna
start taking the approach that you have
about sick and tired of seeing you
shirtless on twitter i'm sick and tired
of people sending me memes of you
running through me
dk okay that's i guess we have that in
common
okay yes sir
you take care of yourself dk metcalf
have a great uh weekend and we'll chat
down the road
all right yes sir let's race again
sometime okay
oh hey i mean are you serious like
literally for charity would you do that
dk
oh yeah i would do it yes sir oh my gosh
let's but we got to work we got a race
shirtless though
oh my gosh all right well uh you go get
ready for the washington football
team i'm gonna do about a thousand
push-ups okay
let's do that in the interim all right
you take care
all right yes sir i'll talk to you later
right back at you that's dk metcalf
that's amazing
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here